[Music]
you were recently in Sri Lanka and this
has got to be an amazing experience what
are people like over in Sri Lanka very
honest very blunt lunch tell you what
they think all the time yeah um I I went
to the airport and I was this woman I
was doing the metal detector thing all
over my body and she kept like hitting
my boobs and there there
[Applause]
looking down at all ya got to do that or
not not gonna look down at one side
front
I'm gonna talk you to say um and and who
should keep hitting me and I was like
what is he doing and then she looks at
my visa then stares at me and goes
female what did you think I was a boy
she goes yeah can we just start laughing
this room together like manically and
I'm like well I can't believe she
thought I was a boy she's a cat thought
you're a boy oh my god
take care I walked and I meet my friend
oh my gosh go use the restroom someone
just saw was a boy she's like really as
I kind of know I go to the restroom and
outside it's like a woman mopping and
she looks at me she goes gentlemen that
way what is going on and I was like
maybe I just used the guy's restroom
since everyone thinks I'm a guy and I
was like no forget it I'm gonna show
this woman when I'm about I go back
because I was just in the corner kind of
looking at the wall questioning life and
I marched back up there she's not in for
the door open the door and she's mopping
inside she goes gentleman out there and
everyone's staring at me horrified that
there's a bully in there yeah
and I pull out my visa I'm like I am a
girl I have to go pee excuse me and as I
approach the stall this woman who's like
applying makeup she goes oh it's cuz we
we thought you're a boy cuz your face it
looks like a boy I'm pretty aware that
you thought my appearance would look
like a boy cuz you guys are all scanned
she goes in your body
she said that do you know I'm a girl
yes yes I do did you say to her I said
okay
[Applause]
I'm afraid
we're completely out of time
[Applause]